[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here with
your first look at the most anticipated
phone of 2019 so far from Samsung and
that turns out it's actually three
phones there is the Samsung Galaxy S 10
the galaxy s 10 plus and the galaxy s 10
II so three new phones each of them
familiar in many ways is a Samsung phone
but each of them also has their
differences so first off here I'm gonna
focus on the two main ones that say the
flagships the galaxy s 10 and the galaxy
s 10 plus and I'm off the bet they do
look pretty good I mean I never thought
Samsung phones were ugly at all but
these look quite nice we kind of saw
this coming from the renders so first
off the new stuff for the galaxy s 10
there are three main improvements and
then a lot of small ones but the main
ones are the display the fingerprint
sensor and the cameras so the new
display it's simple you can see it it's
got a 6.1 inch display for the s 10 at a
six point four inch display in the s 10
plus and they continue the tradition of
Samsung having literally the best
displays in any phone for a couple years
running now and it continues to get even
better so you have a 90 plus percent
screen to body ratio now and it's still
a super-high resolution with a 19 by 9
tall aspect ratio but it's now also HDR
10 plus certified and they've changed
the name a little bit they're calling it
a next-level infinity display but still
it goes right up to the very edges and
you have of course your camera cutout
right there in the top right corner like
we've seen in all the leaks
it is a laser-cut hole in the AMOLED
panel to precisely cut this hole for
just the camera to come through and
nothing else and it's a single 10
megapixel selfie camera for the galaxy s
10 plus an additional depth sensor next
to it for the dual cutout in the S 10
plus so no ultra wide selfie camera
sadly but yeah I guess now seeing that
cut out in person here instead of just
in a leak or a render it doesn't really
shock them anymore like we've seen this
design start to come up we saw it in
that one on her phone but it was on the
left hand side this time it's on the
right it seems like Samsung's cutout is
maybe a little just a little bit smaller
than honours it's not too distracting it
pushes the battery and the signal
indicators over from the right edge and
of course Samsung will cleverly include
a bunch of wallpapers that's slightly
dark in the top right hand corner to
make the whole bunch less jarring and
they also draw this fancy animation
around the
when you switch to the front-facing
camera so I guess they're kind of
embracing it so there it is Samsung can
now say they've technically never done a
notch I guess alright so number two the
number two main new thing is the new
fingerprint sensor Galaxy S ten has
officially moved to the ultrasonic under
the glass fingerprint reader which is
pretty dope so you see the word
ultrasonic in there and that's not just
a name they're just making up that
actually means something as far as the
technologies use for you and I so we've
had under the glass fingerprint sensors
in phones before namely in phones like
the oneplus 60 but they've mostly been
optical fingerprint sensors shining a
light on your finger to actually read
your fingerprint these ultrasonic ones
don't use that so they have a couple of
Vantage's number one they'll be faster
number two they don't need to shine up
super bright light on your finger to
read it so it'll be way less annoying
and dim light or at night and number
three it can read the fingerprints
before waking up the display at all that
is a pretty sweet feature that I'm
really happy about so the ultrasonic
fingerprint sensor I'm looking forward
to using so then that brings us to
number three the third main new feature
with galaxy s 10 which is the cameras
plural so galaxy s 10 now has the triple
cameras on the back so Samsung is
finally doing the three different focal
lengths one main camera one telephoto
and one super wide which is sick I've
been waiting for that and I hope Apple
gets on this train next so Samsung has
had for a while one of the best cameras
in any smartphone so fingers crossed
this continued improvement and image
quality and color science keeps going
we'll find out all these things in the
full review so definitely make sure you
subscribe to see that when it comes out
but the new cameras on the back are
already welcome the main camera is a 12
megapixel sensor dual aperture F 1.5 or
2.4 with oh is then the telephoto is
also f 2.4 and has OIS and the ultra
wide it doesn't have oh is but you
hardly need it at 123 degrees anyway and
it opens up to F 2.2 I for one hope
everyone adopts some sort of ultra wide
camera I personally love the look and
then in software like Apple and Huawei
and LG have done you can sort of
seamlessly zoom between the cameras and
it'll switch automatically which camera
Iran depending on how far you zoomed in
it also keeps the intelligent camera
with the improved scene recognition and
all that honestly it's looking like a
winning package in the camera Department
but of course we have to test that all
to find out matter of fact make sure
you're following me on Twitter and also
Instagram to see those sample photos of
this when I start to get it it goes from
the day that this video gets uploaded
and posted I'm already gonna start
posting sample photos so you can see
those so that's it for the main changes
but of course since it's Samsung they've
thrown in a ton of other little stuff
because that's their style and it's good
stuff
so first of all the batteries are
significantly bigger galaxy s 10 is now
a thirty four hundred million power
battery and Galaxy S ten plus is now a
4100 milliamp hour battery so that's
nice and the specs and materials are
variable so the one constant is
Snapdragon 85 through everything that's
great then the Galaxy S ten starts at
nine hundred bucks and for that you get
eight gigs of RAM and 128 gigs of
storage but there's also an eight and
512 version then the s10 plus starts at
a thousand bucks which gets you eight
gigs of RAM and 128 gigs of storage
again but if you spec it up as 10 plus
turns into a ceramic back instead of
glass and then there's an 8 by 512
version or a ridiculous 1 terabyte model
with 12 gigs of RAM so I don't know if
you maybe you have a habit of of
bragging about how much RAM your phone
has dear friends I don't know what kind
of person would use twelve gigs of RAM
but hey you can do it now twelve gigs of
ram in a phone and let's not forget
samsung phones also have expandable
storage via microsd so you can have a
terabyte of internal and a half a
terabyte microSD card
so 1.5 terabytes of memory so straight
off the bat with just that Galaxy S 10
and S 10 plus are looking like some
really impressive
obviously wellspect flagships for 2019
and all of that takes us to Samsung's
other phone that might kind of get lost
in all this which is galaxy s 10 II and
I didn't want that to get buried or
anything so I have an entire separate
video just on the galaxy s 10a and
everything that's new with it and
different from these s10 s so you can
click here to watch that or it'll be the
first link below that like button but
that's the s10 II bottom line with it
it's essentially their answer to the
iPhone 10 R it has a couple of
trade-offs like a regular fingerprint
sensor and a
slightly smaller display etc to make
that lower price but it doesn't cut off
too much and it ends up at 750 bucks so
it's a pretty direct comparison there
and then Samsung also dropped this
little bomb on us the Galaxy S 10 5g now
this we know even less about we just
know it's gonna be a bigger s10 with a
six point seven inch screen and a huge
battery and an even bigger price but
also aside from the shots you just saw
me get of it they wouldn't let me record
any of it they wouldn't let me turn it
on the screen doesn't turn on and they
wouldn't let me hold it which leads me
to believe that could have easily just
been a model of a phone that phone
doesn't exist yet it's coming out in
allegedly q2 of 2019 but that would be a
whole separate thing when that comes out
but anyway yeah as you can see from the
S 10 and s 10 plus and from the spec
sheets and from holding them they
continue the Samsung tradition of
checking all the boxes they possibly can
still of course it has ip68 it has fast
charging fast wireless charging the
headphone jack is still there it has
Wi-Fi 6 the Bigsby button did yeah the
Bigsby button still there
it's whatever they check the box but
there's also this feature now called
wireless power share aka
reverse wireless charging so Samsung
gets on board with that too kind of like
we saw with the huawei mate 20 pro
earlier so now galaxy s 10 will be able
to enable troll mode super slow four
point five watt qi wireless charging of
other devices i mean it's fine that it
works i said it before but it's it's
pretty gimmicky I wouldn't want to
actually do this unless it's a literal
emergency but it's more for accessories
like the new Galaxy buds they're
wireless earbuds that have achieved
while discharging case also word on the
street is Apple may be thinking of doing
this for the new iPhone with the new air
pods - which may have a wireless case
but that's all maybe stuff we'll see so
finally to top everything off there are
some new colors
none of them look that amazing to me I
mean the green is kind of cool but I'll
probably end up going with black they're
all glass so they're all gonna have
fingerprints and then of course you'll
notice they're running Samsung's new
improved one UI which is actually
visually pretty different from previous
versions of Samsung skins and the main
thing you'll notice when using it is it
moves a
ton of things like menu items and quick
toggles and controls to the bottom of
the display so everything is more
reachable on these huge phones and it's
just overall more well thought-out and
well-designed than previous Samsung
software at least in my opinion then
again some things are also cartoonishly
huge and I wish they would be smaller or
a bit more subtle or less crazy colorful
I don't know I'm working on my thoughts
on it but so far it's looking pretty
solid but from my time with the hands-on
that's pretty much it honestly I was
impressed I mean I like the way the
phones look and feel in the hands so for
my 900 bucks or a thousand bucks I think
I'm pretty into it of course the full
review will be the tell-all but what do
you think is this enough to actually get
you to change your mind also this video
is brought to you by the newest round of
mkbhd apparel this hoodie is in the
latest drop it is live on the site right
now and it is legitimately the softest
hoodie I've ever worn like that's not
even a joke in my lifetime this is the
softest one so pretty big fan link is
below anyway that is it
that's s10 and s11 - the s10 evideo is
below but feel free to share this video
with anyone who'd be curious about
Samsung's new tenth generation flagships
until the next one thanks for watching
catch you guys later peace